chantal hébert à montréal marie vastel à
tahoua michel david à montréal bonsoir
monsieur dan bon ton en soit si vous le
voulez bien on va écouter une seconde
le chef démissionnaire du bloc québécois
gilles duceppe avec l'élection de dix
députés l'avenir de notre formation est
assurée pour les quatre prochaines
années
j'aurais évidemment aimé en obtenir
davantage et est moi même élu dans ma
circonscription mais somme toute je
quitte avec le sentiment du devoir
accompli
nous avons représenté le québec avec
rigueur avec dignité et avec un sens
aigu des responsabilités sous ma
direction le bloc a été le parti de tous
les québécois et de toutes les
québécoises sans exceptions en
particulier des plus humbles d'entre
nous alors voilà vous l'avez entendu un
michel david deux premières questions
lui doit se dire qu'il a des missions
accomplies sans moi peut-être le bloc a
réussi hier aux députés la dix députés
c'est pas si mal je peux partir l'esprit
en paix
comprenez ça comme ça moi il peut partir
de toute façon rester après les deux des
flics monsieur s'approprie dans la rue
sainte-marie s'arrêter du masochisme
plus récents et pendant je pense qu'ils
étaient je me demande même comment on a
pu penser qu'ils auraient pu rester
pour ce qui est de la première partie de
votre question c'est clair que sans
monsieur duceppe
le bloc aurait fait pire il a fait une
bonne campagne objectivement c'est
certain on peut programmer monsieur
duceppe d'aucune façon
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'est ce que ça
veut dire de conserver bloc à ottawa
dans ces circonstances là écoutez tant
que le bloc
faisait face à un gouvernement qui avait
une poignée de députés à québec on
pouvait mais bon oui défense des
intérêts du québec mais là on a un
gouvernement qui peut s'appuyer sur sur
une base de 40 députés plus de la moitié
des députés québécois sont libéraux
maintenant l'argument de la défense
traditionnel des intérêts du québec et
beaucoup moins valables chantal c'est ça
va se poser l'euro le réel et est ce que
le bloc peut même pas devenir un poids
pour le mouvement souverainiste
québécois mais il l'a déjà été dans la
mesure où le résultat de lundi soir est
pas un résultat qui donne de l'élan au
mouvement souvenirs c'est plutôt genre
de résultat qui fait un peu mouillé le
on regarde ça moins de 20% du vote
michel parlait de la majorité des
députés du québec qui était libéraux en
plus et ça aussi c'est différent ça
change la donne il ya plus de députés
néo démocrates du québec à la chambre
des communes que deux bloquistes et il
ya plus de députés conservateurs du
québec à la chambre des communes que le
blocus est alors au niveau de la
vocation d'un parti c'est pas évident
monsieur duceppe a rappelé aujourd'hui
il sait ce que ça veut dire avoir le
statut officiel à la chambre des
communes
ça voudrait aussi pas avoir beaucoup de
visibilité marie vastel ottawa comment
ça va fonctionner d'après vous comment
ils vont s'organiser les yahia le chef
parlementaire a bien sûr le doyen la
chambre des communes mais sinon comment
vous voyez les prochains prochains mois
en terme de chefferie de toute façon
monsieur duceppe aurait probablement pas
été atteint à tous les jours du fait
qu'il ait pas député il le pote de
budget de logements pour avoir une
deuxième résidence donc de toute façon
il aurait dû se trouver quelqu'un pour
parler en leur nom à ottawa je suis
d'accord avec mes collègues que la
visibilité va être difficile ils sont
les moins nombreux au niveau du caucus
québécois est totale mais en même temps
ça peut peut-être les aider de faire
face à un gouvernement libéral parce que
si il y à des positions de monsieur
trudeau qui sont pas tout à fait au
diapason avec celle du gouvernement du
québec
reste que le bloc sera le mieux placé
car il n'aura pas de compromis à faire
comme il aime
le rappeler pour défendre ses positions
québécoises là il reste encore 16
députés du npd au québec mais il compte
quand même pour une plus petite part du
caucus que avant l'élection de lundi où
ils étaient majoritaires ils avaient
peut-être plus de facilité à imposer
leur leurs préférences ou leurs
positions et là il se retrouve en
minorité ce sera peut être plus dur de
faire valoir leur point de vue et donc
ça serait peut-être l'occasion pour le
bloc de se faire valoir davantage s'il
ya ces situations-là très bien bon on
verra les prochains mois mais se faire
entendre
ça va être leur premier défi parce qu'on
le sait il ya moins de visibilité moins
de visibilité on s'habitue à les voir
moins bon c'est un cercle peut devenir
vicieux derrière monsieur duceppe qui en
veut un peu je crois aux médias pour
cette campagne
il juge qu'on ne sait pas assez
intéressé à lui et au bloc québécois
mais bon ça ce sera pour les congrès de
la fpjq je veux vous amener sur stéphane
bédard je veux qu'on les écoute d'abord
monsieur le président vous annonce que
je quitte mes fonctions de député de
chicoutimi je serai toujours
reconnaissant redevable de l'affection
et de l'apli que la population m'a
témoignée à chaque jour je leur ai donné
le meilleur de moi même j'en ai fait de
même pour le parti québécois auquel je
suis profondément attachée et avec qui
je partage d'ailleurs le même nombre
d'années d'existence boncelles ce départ
l'on n'avait pas vu venir michel à
québec c'est quand même dur coup pour le
parti québécois il est au fils de marc
andré bédard elle est là depuis 17 ans
ancien leader parlementaire fait quand
même une figure importante qu'est ce que
vous en dites ah bon les repas vu venir
et je suis pas mal convaincu que même
super ladoux l'avait pas vu venir
oui à mon sens c'est un coût beaucoup
plus dur pour le mouvement souverainiste
que le départ de monsieur duceppe
monsieur bédard nous a donné quelques
raisons de les écouter la famille la
fatigue après 17 ou 18 ans dix
parlementaires
non non non je ne suis pas frustré
d'avoir perdu mon poste de leader
parlementaire mais posons la question
autrement si monsieur bédard avait eu le
sentiment que la souveraineté était à
portée de main que le pq avait une
chance de gagner la prochaine élection s
qui seraient partis je pense que poser
la question c'est y répondre
donc ce départ l'homme me donne à penser
que même chez des péquistes qui devrait
normalement
trouvé dans l'arrivée de monsieur
péladeau une nouvelle raison 3 il y a de
sérieux doutes et c'est un nom d'un
chantage c'est quelqu'un qui avait un
tirant d'eau c'est quelqu'un dans le
caucus qui est important aussi c'est pas
très bons moments de joie et d'ailleurs
il ya vaut lui attend d'eux après
l'élection parce que par des arrêtés
encore pire ouais mais ça donne à la
journéeles et à la semaine l'impression
d'une semaine d'enfer
le genre semaine horribilis pour pas
parlé d'années que de voir ces deux
événements leur arrivée coup sur coup et
avec un nouveau cherche d'accord avec
michel si on avait l'impression que le
parti québécois est ce une grande lancé
d'abord les résultats du bloc serait
peut-être différent et d'autre part
monsieur bédard encore marie vastel de
d'ottawa le mouvement souverainiste
commun et comment il est perçu parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'analystes qui vont
dans le sens de ce qu'on vient
d'entendre tous les gens se disent c'est
vraiment un mouvement affaibli
très affaiblie actuellement c'est sûr
que comme dit chantal coup sur coup la
même journée c'est moyen comme message
monsieur bédard a beau dire que ça rien
à voir avec ça sa foi en la possibilité
d'atteindre la sueur intéresse que comme
dit michel poser la question c'est y
répondre
en plus donc il ya cette deuxième
défaite historique du bloc lundi et le
fait ou si je trouve que me succède dans
les dernières semaines de la campagne
parler mais en parler mais insiste est
de moins en moins sur l'indépendance
peut prendre pays c'est prendre parti
c'est prendre pays il a ajusté son
discours pour vraiment insisté sur le
fait qu'il pouvait porter la balance du
pouvoir et envoi je veux dire sillage
son discours pour parler - souveraineté
et pour parler de la pertinence ou de
l'utilité du bloc de façon générale
c'est que visiblement lui aussi sentait
que le message ne passait probablement
pas tellement bien avait auprès de
l'électorat
voilà avant de se quitter une photo un
moment ce matin vous savez qu'avec cette
cérémonie de commémoration des
événements dit à alain de l'attentât où
neten cirilo a été abattu
regardez donc deux premiers mines et
c'était photos rares au canada compte
tenu du contexte
les voici c'est cette photo que vous
verrez un peu partout demain un mot
là-dessus je disais un peu plus tôt en
nouvelles ya eu un avant et un après cet
événement là ottawa comme si on avait
perdu un peu de notre innocence au
canada chantal moi j'ai l'impression que
la photo a plutôt rendu les gens heureux
du résultat électoral il ya un aspect il
y avait une espèce l'impression de
réconciliation dans cette photo là je
vais regarder moi surtout stephen harper
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait l'air de
quelqu'un qui était assez serein avec le
résultat tout à fait c'est oui je crois
que vous avez tout à fait raison
michel david vous avez suivi un plus
vous avez vu ça oui bien sûr il me
semble que quand même l'élection de
résultats de la dernière élection me
donne à penser que malgré le traumatisme
de la perte d'innocence dont dont vous
avez parlé
les canadiens ont pas encore l'obsession
de la sécurité comme monsieur harper a
voulu leur inculquer alors j'ai
l'impression que c'est une mauvais
souvenir qu'on n'oubliera pas mais qui
nous paralyse rappaz comme comme
canadien avec de la sérénité c'est ce
qu'on sentait bon état ce matin tout à
fait marie vastel oui non mais je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec chantal et moi
aussi j'ai trouvé que étonnamment
monsieur un peu avait l'air assez serein
il y avait d'autres photos ci qui
circulait sur tout et tous ont envoyé
les deux couples madame et monsieur un
peu madame et monsieur trudeau qui
parlaient en souriant sa valeur quand
même agréable conversation cccc beau
avoir tant mieux et sur le après 22
octobre
je pense que ce que ça change c'est
peut-être aussi pour nous au parlement
je voudrais que c'est de plus en plus
difficile de rentrer et donc je me
demande il y avait des sexes là ce matin
qui dit qu'il s'était encore à l'étude
ce qu'on pouvait faire de plus et donc
je me demande ce que ça peut vouloir
dire pour l'accès au public au parlement
mais ce sera pour un autre jour mais
effectivement on est plus traumatisés
comme on l'était il ya un an mais reste
que ça laisse des séquelles comme en
témoigne le projet doit ses 51 comme en
témoigne beaucoup de choses dont il va
falloir parler dans le nouveau
gouverneur d'intrus d'eau et on en
parlera de ce nouveau gouvernement merci
beaucoup un chantage avait été d'une
grande fidélité avec nous on va se
peut-être au cours des événements
politiques des prochaines mois se
retrouver épisodiquement chef david eux
mêmes choses avoue marie vastel merci et
à la prochaine
avant au revoir